The Joe Rogan Experience now Daryl I
want to talk to you about your personal
experience on Minds with this uh with
what you what you do what you're known
for have you had interactions with
people on Minds that have been favorable
that have you've kind of pushed people
into a I've had yeah I've had a few and
I've had you know my share of detractors
some people think you know what I'm
doing is totally wrong and don't get me
or whatever but yeah I've had it I've
had interactions with some people when
when you say like people have said it's
totally wrong like what what kind of
criticisms do they have for that uh it
depends upon where they're coming from
um some people think it's not my job to
teach white people how to treat us
US mean black people uh others think
it's ridiculous to sit down with a white
supremacist why you know why why would
you waste your time uh you know those
people can't change would you point to
your success ratio because it's pretty
amazing oh yeah I point to that you know
but a lot of people you know they don't
see that because they don't they would
not tolerate the time to sit down right
and have somebody tell them some
nonsense that Jews or the Childs of the
devil or you know some crazy yeah things
like that uh I will sit and listen to
that and I will put up with it uh
because in order for me to uh speak my
mind I have to listen to somebody else's
yes right so they're not willing to to
put in that time I am yeah and so when
how do you have the time to do this this
is what I do you know in between my
music gigs yeah but I mean like that's
what kind of commitment are you talking
about like how much time do you spend
doing this a lot I mean it's my life now
how many like email dialogue oh God I
get I get emails all the time I've got
emails from people I don't even know I
even get emails from people who've seen
me on podcasts or on TV shows these are
white supremacist Clans or whatever and
say you know you made some sense you
know would you like my robe I've even
gotten robes yeah in the mail from
people I don't even know yes yeah I
think there's a lot of sad people that
just need a group of people to belong to
and they'll decide that what these
people are saying makes sense because at
least they'll be a part of it let me
explain something to you
as you already know one's perception is
one's reality okay
you cannot change anybody's reality if
you try to change the reality you're
going to get pushed back because they
only know what they know whether it's
real or not it's their reality so what
you want to do is you want to offer them
a better alternative perception and if
they resonate with your perception then
they will change their own reality
because their perception becomes their
reality it's just a quick example let's
say you got a seven or eight year old
brother right and he goes to a magic
show with his buddies and he comes back
and tells you Joe you know this magician
he asked for a female volunteer and 50
women raised their hand he picked up
this one come up on stage he told her to
climb into this long box and stick her
feet out that hole and put her head out
this hole and then he closed the lid
told her to wiggle her feet and she
kicked her legs and they took a chainsaw
I went and cut that box in half he cut
that woman in half and you're like ah it
didn't really happen like that yes it
did I was there you weren't even there I
saw it with my own eyes you are
challenging his reality he knows what he
saw and that magician cut that woman in
half and then to make it even more
obvious to you he tells you that the
magician after you cut the Box in half
took the half with the leg sticking out
and moved it over here stays right and
the half with the head over here at a
stage left and then he went over there
and talked to the head of the woman and
she talked back to him and then he
brought the two halves back together
opened the box and now popped a woman
full form no blood he cut her in half
and he put it back together and you're
saying uh it was just an illusion no it
wasn't I saw it with my own eyes I was
there you weren't even there so again
you're attacking his reality he's going
to resist he's going to fight you all
right so what you do is you offer him a
better perception you say Hey listen I
hear what you're saying but could it be
possible that just maybe
out of those 50 women that raised their
hands and he picked one maybe she works
for him maybe he planted her in the
audience she knows the trick she travels
to every show around the country with
him and when she gets in the Box there's
a pair of mannequin legs laying on the
floor of the box that are wearing the
same stockings and same shoes that she
has on she picks him up shows them out
the hole when he says move your feet
she'll shakes those things and then she
brings her own legs up under her chest
so her whole body is on that half of the
box so the saw doesn't even touch her
and obviously when he separates the two
halves the feet are over there and now
she can't move them so he has to
distract your attention by going over
here so you're not looking at those feet
and he's talking to the head and she's
talking back of course when he brings
them back together she pulls the dummy
legs leaves them on the floor of the Box
she climbs out and then your brother
says hmm
you know I guess that would be the only
way that would work you've offered him a
better perception and that perception
then becomes his reality so don't attack
somebody's reality regardless of what it
is even if you know it to be false give
them a better perception and allow them
to resonate with it because it's always
better when somebody comes comes to the
conclusion I've been wrong maybe this is
something I need to think about yeah
this will work it's a perfect example of
not silencing people's ideas but giving
them better ideas and this is what the
answer to censorship has been exactly
and uh you know so Daryl always talks
about how much he listens when he starts
a dialogue and doesn't even try to you
know push ideas at the people that he's
engaging with different extremists or
whatnot would you agree with that
statement absolutely and let me just
give you an example of that okay so
I'm interviewing a clan leader white
supremacist right and I ask you know how
can you hate me you don't even know me
you know all you see is this come in my
room five minutes ago and and you're
you've already determined you know
whatever you determine well Mr Davis you
know black people are prone to crime and
that is evidenced by the fact that there
are more blacks in prison than white
people now I'm just sitting here
listening to this guy he's calling me a
criminal and um but he's right he's a
hundred percent right the data and the
uh statistics show that there are more
blacks in prison than white people so
that feeds what he already thinks he
knows the data right but he does not go
to find out why does that data show that
uh he doesn't realize there may be an
imbalance in our judicial system that
send black people to prison for longer
periods of time than white people who've
committed the same crime all right so I
just listened to him right because when
he walks in that room and he sees me I'm
the enemy his wall goes up his ears are
like this you know he's ready to defend
whatever his stance is so I'm just
listening and then he goes and say you
know uh black people are inherently lazy
uh they always have their hand out for a
freebie uh they're always trying to scam
the government welfare programs and all
that kind of stuff so now he's caught
he's called me a criminal and now he's
calling me lazy and I'm just sitting
here listening I'm not pushing back and
then he says uh and black people are
born with smaller brains and the larger
the brain the more capacity for
intelligence the smaller the brain the
lower the IQ so now I'm being called
stupid now it's what he says that this
is evidenced by the fact that every year
the data shows that black high school
students consistently score lower on the
SATs than our white kids do again he's
100 correct that does show that right
but he doesn't realize why all right uh
where do most black kids in this country
go to school in the inner city where do
most white kids go to school in the
suburbs it is a fact Suburban schools
are better funded they have better
facilities better teachers Etc I will
guarantee you white kids who go to
school in the inner city can score just
as low as those black kids if not some
lower black kids who go to school in the
suburbs can score just as high as the
white kids if not higher it has
absolutely nothing to do with the color
of this of the student's skin or the
size of the student's brain but has
everything to do with the educational
system in which that child is enrolled
but of course he won't go to research
that because the data already supports
what he already believes that I'm
inferior so now he's called me all these
things
um I've already done my research on him
I know this guy sitting across from me
just barely made it out of high school I
have a college degree so do I throw that
in his face no but because I sat there
and listened to him that wall is coming
down because you cannot impart
information to somebody when the wall is
up it's like hitting a brick wall you
want that wall to come down and then the
ears open up so now he's exhausted all
his vitriol and now he's wondering like
how can this black person isn't pushing
up against me like most of them do and
he's curious as to what I think about
what he just said so now the wall is
down and he feels compelled to
reciprocate because I sat there and
listened to him insult me so now it's my
turn I could go on the offense and say
no you are the one who's a criminal
you're the one hanging black men from
trees and dragging them behind pickup
trucks and bombing their churches and I
would be 100 correct because the clan
has over a hundred year history of doing
that but if I did that that wall would
go right back up so I don't want that to
happen I want to keep the wall down and
let him hear what I'm saying so I say so
rather than go on the offense I'll go on
the defense and I say listen I hear what
you're saying however I don't have a
criminal record and I'm as black as
anybody you've ever seen so I don't have
a criminal record
um I've never been on welfare
as far as my brain size goes I've never
measured the size of my brain but I'm
sure it's the same size as anybody
else's and as far as my SAT scores go
they got me into college now I already
know that he doesn't have a college
degree I do does it make me a better
person than him no but it gives me a
better experience right so I let him
know this he goes home
and he thinks just like we all do at the
end of the day we reflect on what we did
during the day he thinks man I just had
a three-hour conversation with a black
guy you know when we didn't come to
blows and what that Daryl guy said
it makes sense oh but he's black
but what he said was true but he's black
so they're having a cognitive dissonance
yeah right and they struggle with that
for a while and then they had that
dilemma I got to make my mind what am I
going to do so the The Dilemma is do I
disregard whatever color he is and
believe the truth because I know it to
be true and change my ideological
direction or do I consider the color of
his skin and continue living a lie in
most cases people will follow the truth
but then there will be those who don't
want to give it the power or the
notoriety or whatever and they will
follow the LIE well the way you're doing
it is brilliant because you're you're
doing it so patiently
and contrary to the way most people
handle arguments most people handle
arguments by trying to shut down the
other person's argument and [ __ ] all
over them instead of trying to what
you're saying offer an alternative
perspective which is really probably the
only way to get people to think about
things in a different light and Joe that
comes from the fact that I've done a lot
of travel okay I've been exposed to
people from all over the world and we
all got along we all got along we told a
story on the podcast the first time you
hear about not even understanding racism
until you were a child because you grew
up overseas right exactly and we got so
I saw that so I saw something that they
have not seen right and that's why I
want to share that with them vicariously
to let them know no it's you know the
whole every white person uh in the world
is not like every white person in this
country every black person in the world
is not like every black person in this
country you know uh there are white
people over in France like in the 1940s
and 50s a lot of black Americans moved
to France to live some even gave up
their U.S citizenship because the French
people were treating them as they didn't
see color you know and those French
people were a lot more white than the
white people here in this country who
might be mixing something else so you
know people need to see in fact my
favorite quote of all time is by Mark
Twain or otherwise known as Samuel
Clemens it's called the travel quote and
Mark Twain said quote unquote travel is
fatal to Prejudice bigotry and
narrow-mindedness and many of our people
need it thoroughly on these accounts
broad wholesome charitable views of men
and things cannot be acquired by
vegetating in one little corner of the
Earth all one's lifetime that guy was so
good wasn't he he had so many great
quotes exactly isolation and so Sam
Harris actually did a study that we talk
about in the in the paper about he did a
Neuro Imaging study of people being
exposed to political beliefs different
from their own and actually looked at
people's brains when they were going
through this experience and they
actually talked about this thing called
the backfire effect which is sort of
what you're talking about when the
Wall's up
and so they sort of detected that
interestingly
um and I forget the exact name of the
study but it's it's in the footnotes
so
I think the patience is it
that it's long term if you're not
changing someone's mind like in five
minutes of you know chattering on in
comment sections or you know yelling at
someone at the dinner table like that
you barely know like Daryl knows how to
create long-term relationships and not
be like thirsty for them to change their
mind like it's just by like look we're
here we're hanging out whether it's a
network or you know offline or online
network doesn't really matter and so I
think the backfire effect that that Sam
found and that we're sort of talking
about with walls going up is very real
and that's why
it's just it has to be long term you
know but Daryl I'm just thinking while
I'm listening here like these
conversations that you've had with these
white supremacists and neo-nazis how
amazing would it be if that was a
podcast
no what I'm saying if you sat down with
those people from the beginning from
first meeting them and see that
conversation play out that would be very
related I've got some of that do you
know where where I've sat down with some
of these people while they were still in
and now I'm sitting down with them now
that they're out some of them even come
on my lecturers with me and stand on
stage with me and speak out against
their former you have videos of these
conversations yeah some of them yeah God
are they online uh some of them I think
are but if not I can send you some I
think those videos would be a great tool
for someone that's maybe trapped but
like at least partially open-minded
where they have this like view of things
like maybe I'm incorrect about this
maybe I need to reevaluate yeah you know
like that at but as a podcast that would
be brilliant